barbara in dallas texas so hey how's it
going what can i do how can i help
okay uh so i'm calling to ask
about how i can navigate my husband
most likely being an alcoholic i'm
getting to
yeah i'm getting to a point where i
don't want to be
in this anymore if i'm going to have to
be the adult
every single night and put our kids to
bed while he's like
junk a little too much he's not going to
sleep on the couch
um so we are both 25 we're married and
we have a toddler and a newborn
and why why it hurts so much to me is
for one obviously i love this guy
i do not want to see him go down a hole
and then two
my parents have gone through so much to
intergenerational curse of alcoholism
and obviously with that being said we
both come from families who have
or still abuse alcohol and i just really
don't want to get to a point where
i'm going to be in the hospital and i'm
going to find myself
being my husband with liver cirrhosis or
just something like that and i deserve
better he deserves
deserves better and our children do too
yeah
i'm i'm high-fiving you and i'm
heartbroken for you i'm hugging you and
high-fiving at the same time
um i'm so sorry that's happening um so
walk let's walk back a little bit is
this new behavior
or has he always been the guy that had
one or two too many but he was funny
about it he was silly about it
but and now it's it's starting to wear
on you because you got little kids or
has this
come on in the last couple of years as
you've
brought toddlers home into the house um
okay so we've been together since we
were about
15 14 or 15 years old so all throughout
high school he like was very adamant
about
not drinking not doing any of that
and then after high school we had a
breakup and then he ended up
dropping out of college and in that
date that he was in of like
our breakup him leaving school i guess
he felt like
in a sense he wasn't good enough so of
course there was some sort of trauma i
guess
from that and that's whenever he started
developing had a habit
and then we got together so that was in
2015
we had broken up for a year and so i
guess he developed
those in 2015-26 and so
we got back together in 2016
and eventually got married in 2018
and in 2018 it wasn't as bad but i could
see there was um
for lack of better words uh demons that
he
brought along into our marriage that he
didn't
put down so why did you marry a guy that
you saw
with a problem um i guess
i'm i guess you can say i'm a fixer
person
like i thought us getting married and
planning our future was going to like
send a an alarm in his head like saying
oh
there's something better for me barbara
you are sweet and kind like me
i thought that the country would just
come together and look at that so look
at us
right we're such a naive optimist so
yeah um does he have alcoholism in his
family
or mental health issues or trauma in his
family he's got it too
yeah he his dad passed away
at a very young age his stepdad
uh i i hate to say this but i think is
that that has a drinking problem too
okay um and i think uh it's it was more
of a learned behavior for him
because his stepdad started drinking
whiskey and the next thing you know a
month later
my husband's going to specs and buying a
bottle whiskey i'm just
like so so how
when you sat down and talked to him how
does that conversation go
um he thinks i'm belittling him okay
are you and that no not at all
i i've come from a family
like where my dad used to do that when i
was a very very very small child
i barely remember it and i know
that it can lead to so many other
uh bigger problems and i just don't want
him
to find himself in a big problem where
he can't sure he thinks he can't get out
of
because whenever you drink you're it's
not really you
you're being controlled by that
substance well sometimes and if you're
an alcoholic and you've got a problem
and you're intoxicate all the time then
yeah so so how can i help you
i just i don't know how to help him
so the i'm gonna be totally honest with
you okay
okay um both up and down number one
you can't you can't make him do anything
you can't um weaponizing
your body weaponizing your kids
weaponizing the home and family he has
won't fix that problem um
a great mighty um blowout fight won't
fix that problem
he's gonna have to make a decision that
he's gonna have to plug in
and be the dad that those kids
desperately deserve
that he is not going to
continue a legacy that wasn't his
biological dad's fault he passed away
he's not but he's got a legacy in his
soul now of a
disconnection between a son and his dad
and alcohol fills that for a while
it actually works that's the problem
with it it works for a while and it
helps
numb that um that forest fire in your
soul
for a season right until it burns
everything around you down
um he's gonna have to learn some
behaviors and decide i'm gonna be the
kid that these
i'm gonna be the father these kids
deserve and what you're gonna have to do
is develop boundaries and be real honest
with him
and you're gonna have to get a community
of people around you and he's gonna need
people in his life
and there is a chance that a
a a letter that he can hear that you
write that is not
going to war with him but his compassion
and letting him know that you're
that you love him and you are by him and
he's your guy and you are
in all of this but that you are losing
him
and you want him back and here's what
that's going to look like
here's here's why i like letters and i
say letters almost every show here's why
i like it
when you talk to an addict when you talk
to an angry person and they feel the
slightest bit of
you versus them every wall they have
throws up and they don't hear you
right and then he says things like
you're belittling me you're attacking me
which honestly you might be you may not
feel like you are but
it may be you may be hearing it that way
right a letter allows him
to get defensive and get his feelings
hurt and then come back to it
and then come back to it and you get to
hold it in your hand there's something
about the tactile
it's not an email either especially it's
not a text for god's sake
but you get to hold a handwritten letter
he gets to see your
your um handwriting and there's
something about going back to it going
back to it that it slowly can seep
through you it doesn't always work you
can throw it away you can water up and
throw in a fireplace right
um but letting him know
that you're losing him and that you have
a if he's not hurting your kids and he's
um
he's neglecting your kids let him know
man the kids miss you i miss you
and we and you both probably have some
learning to do
on how to be connected intentional um
uh unified parents oh great i use the
word unity again
there i go throwing liberal propaganda
all over my show being unified parents
right um you're gonna have to both learn
how to do that if you come from a house
alcoholics do
you're gonna have to learn that as well
right but if you offer to do it together
um he may join you he may not
that doesn't mean that you don't have to
you don't need to
go learn some skills on year-round so
write him that letter
and make it heartfelt um take him out
somewhere
or have a place where the kids are gone
you've got a babysitter and y'all can
have a heart
conversation that's not a fight that's
something you all plan together
and that you can he can actually hear
you
and um if you can't he can't have that
then it may just be leaving that letter
for him and letting it marinate
right and then the second thing is you
gotta go start taking care of you
that means i'm gonna recommend you go
see somebody go see a
marriage counselor go see a counselor on
your own and let them know
i've got trauma in my background that
i've got to deal with i need to learn
how to be a
connected good mom no
25 year old married couple
with two little ones are gonna have
great lives right now
they're just not they're gonna be filled
with no sleep and exhaustion and people
walking around looking like they were
hit by a bus
and everybody's falling asleep on the
couch all the time that's part of it
and sometimes getting a counselor that
can walk you through some of that is
is relieving right it gives you some
peace
and hopefully he will see you standing
taller
being more intentional being more
plugged in being more whole
and he's going to want to be a part of
that but all of that rests on on a on a
foundation of you can't solve him
you can't cure him you can't um make him
he's gonna have to make some hard hard
decisions in his own soul
my hope is he's got a couple of men
there in his life um that will be
really up in his face and it will be
intentional with holding him accountable
in a way that you can't and my hope is
that a
letter and a night together that's not a
fight that's not a war but that is a
hey we gotta come together um
he'll hear you he'll finally hear you
this is a hard one barbara and i don't
want to make it light
my guess is you're gonna have some
seasons of rough waters ahead
and don't let any of this
deflect you from the kind of parent and
kind of mom that your kids desperately
desperately deserve
don't let any of this reflect on you
that you have a right
to boundaries you have a right to safety
you have a right to a whole
healthy well life um and
man i hope he plugs in i want you to do
me this huge favor barbara i want you to
write him this letter i want you to
to be vulnerable and have this hard
conversation with him in a compassionate
way
in an offline way in an intentional way
and then i want you to let me know how
that goes and if he doesn't
he didn't hear from you tell him to call
the show and i'd love to talk to him as
well
i've talked to my fair share of 25 year
old texans who love whiskey
and who are struggling with dealing with
two young kids and a wife that loves
them
and i'd love to have that conversation
with him too but thank you so so much
for that call